the family of a Florida woman who died
after being infected by flesh-eating
bacteria at a beach is sounding the
alarm the seventy seventy seven-year-old
Lynn Fleming died late last week after
walking along a popular gulf of mexico
beach near her home CBS this morning
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
following the story Jericka how
concerned should people be about this
well this is a rare occurrence but now
you have more communities in that
Florida area where this happened that
are especially concerned that's because
even when it's diagnosed the effects can
be deadly I'm still numb you know it's
just it's two weeks and I lost my mother
and yeah it's it's been hard
wait Fleming's mother Lynn Fleming was
doing what she loved walking along the
Gulf of Mexico coastline at one of her
favorite Florida beaches went for a walk
around one of the surf walls didn't know
that there was a small ditch there and
she stumbled and fell and hit they had
Bank men on the other side she had a
small little three-quarter inch long cut
right on her shin bone in the days
following her fall in the water
Fleming's condition worsened she was
rushed to the emergency room by
ambulance and was diagnosed with
necrotizing fasciitis a rare but deadly
bacterial infection that kills the body
soft tissue the infection rapidly spread
through Fleming's body she died only two
weeks after her fall
hers is believed to be the second case
of necrotizing fasciitis at a Florida
beach in just the past month a 12 year
old girl contracted a similar bacteria
while vacationing in the state's
Panhandle in early June she survived
thanks to an early diagnosis if the
bacteria gets into the bloodstream and
causes sepsis and multi-system organ
damage then of course the death rate is
much higher up to a third of people who
have this serious infection can die from
it
according to the CDC upwards of 1,200
cases occur in the u.s. each year dr.
William Schaffner says it must be caught
early
fortunately flesh-eating bacterial
infections are not common and the key
thing is of course if you have had any
kind of wound
and you start to feel badly please seek
medical attention right away
Wayde Fleming wants people to recognize
the warning signs so others know what to
look for
maybe if she was diagnosed a little
earlier you know maybe we'd be sitting
here talking to my mom with you know
without a leg but you know with a life
well doctors say if you have an open
wound and you've been in the water look
for early warning signs including fever
severe pain and a rapidly spreading
swollen area some types of this bacteria
can be found in warm brackish like salty
water similar to many spots along the
Gulf a recent study suggests rising
ocean temperatures could help the
bacteria thrive in waters previously
unaffected so you know 1,200 cases every
year but it's something to look out for
especially is the sub we are finally in
the summertime and people are heading to
the beach it's confusing though because
typically you think of going in the
water of the salt water is helping heal
a wound right absolutely my mother's
advice to you as a little boy in South
Florida yeah so terrifying you also
don't think you're gonna lose your life
just because you take a simple tumble
and you get a little cut on your leg
right okay I'll wash it off put that
neosporin on and keep going right and
exit even if it hurts the next day I
wouldn't think I need to go the doctor
right slice it feel differently yeah
listening to you all right Eureka thank
you very much